esta rueda de prensa se llevó a cabo en
estos Jardines de la catedral de Santo
Sofía que se encuentra a mis espaldas y
es un día bastante significativo como lo
recalcaron ambos mandatarios la
presidenta de la comisión europea
Bandai Legends dijo básicamente que era
un honor estar aquí el 9 de mayo el día
que Europa celebra su unidad y su
libertad y dijo que esto eran
exactamente los valores por los que
estaba peleando Ucrania en este momento
y dijo que uno de sus valores que había
caracterizado a la Unión Europea durante
todos estos años era la solidaridad y
que venía básicamente a ofrecerle esa
solidaridad y ese apoyo a Ucrania
nuevamente mientras que fuera necesario
y recalcaba que mientras que aquí en
kiev y en el resto del país se luchan
por esos valores incluido la democracia
la libertad de expresión en Rusia por
ejemplo se sacan prisioneros de las
cárceles para llevarlos a pelear en los
frentes de batalla el presidente por su
parte dijo que cada vez que se derribaba
un misil que era lanzado contra el país
en una victoria no solamente de Ucrania
sino del apoyo que le estaba dando
también la Unión Europea y toda la
comunidad internacional y es que anoche
mismo esta madrugada el país volvió a
ser objeto de una nueva oleada de
ataques entre ellos en la ciudad de kiev
donde sonaron las alarmas por varias
horas se sintieron varios ataques pero
realmente fueron explosiones hechas por
las sistemas de defensa antiaéreo que
lograron detener al menos 15 misiles en
un han dicho las autoridades pero no fue
una noche muy amable para todos los que
estuvimos en esta ciudad y así lo
recalcaba el presidente que además había
que entender que la la
presidenta de la comisión europea estaba
camino en un tren hacia la ciudad cuando
en el país entero sonaban las alarmas lo
que aquí se agradeció por su apoyo a
Ucrania y haber estado aquí en un día
tan especial Especialmente cuando
Vladimir Putin ha vuelto a lanzar esta
oleada de ataques contra el país